ben tre
こんにちは井上慎太郎です
私は現在東京大学に在学しています
受験戦争超高難度最難関
そういった言葉がぴったりの東京大学ですが私はそんな大学に少し違った努力をして
入学しました
推薦入試で東京大学に合格したんです
推薦入試では2学校高校でロボット競技に参加して努力を積み重ねた結果
近い大会で入賞したことなどを評価してもらいました
つまり自分が没頭したことをもついて
最難関の大学に合格できたんです
今日は私がロボット競技を通じて得ることができた
歯医者にならない唯一の方法
あなたと共有したいと思います
話は私が中学生の頃に遡ります
私は奈良教育大学附属中学校に描くしました
入学してすぐに入る部活動を決めるわけなんですけど私は運動が苦手だったしかといっ
て音楽ができたり絵を描くのが甘かったわけでもなかったので入る部活を決めかねて
いいかいたんですね
そんな時に科学部に出会いました
科学部の活動内容はいろいろあるんですけど
主にロボット競技に参加している部活動です
私はロボット競技に経験があったわけではなかったんですけど漠然とロボットが楽し
そうだなと思って
入部することに決めました
私が入部して参加することになったのは wro というロボットコンテストです
wro はワールドロボットオリンピアードの略で
簡単に言うとロボットのオリンピックです
7大会から始まりそこで勝ち上がると全国大会がありさらにそこで勝ち上がると世界
大会があります
協議の内容としてはまず毎年ミッションが発表されます
そのミッションをクリアするロボットを専用のレゴブロックで作ってそれを制御する
ようは動かすためのプログラムを書きます
ロボットはラジコンのようにコントローラーで操作されるのではなくてお掃除ロボット
のように書かれたプログラムによって自立して動きます
いわゆる自律制御型のロボットで与えられたミッションをいかに正確にそして早く達成
できるかを競います
私はそのロボット競技にのめり込みます
与えられたミッションをクリアするロボットを一生懸命考えてそれを実際に形にする
さらにそれを自分の思い通りに動かす
こんなに楽しいことはありません
ロボットはとても素直で自分が施した改良をすぐにリアルに反映してくれます
ミッションがクリアできるようになるためにパーツを付け替えたり
プログラムを書き換えたりしていろんなことを試すんです
でも実際ロボットが素直すぎるがゆえに加える改良のほとんどは失敗に終わってしまう
んですね
失敗するたびにまた考えて作り直して試してまた失敗する
そんなことを繰り返しながらついにうまくいった時には喜びと達成感でいっぱいになり
ます
そしてまた新たに改良を加えたくなるんです
ロボットは時間をかければかけるほど自分のこだわりが詰まった
良いものへと進化していきます
ロボットに携わる多くの人がこの魅力に惹かれていることでしょう
私もその一人です
中学2年生になった私はロボットロボットの面白さを原動力に
大会に挑んでいくことになります
奈良大会に出場するまでに
土曜日も日曜日も放課後も毎日活動してすでに7台ものロボットを作っています
その年のミッションは簡単に言うと宝物に見立てた
立方体のブロックを前版通りに改修していくってものだったんですけど
単純にブロックを掴み上げて回収するのではなくてブロックをカゴに向かって横から
叩き入れるという
振り子型のユニークなアームにたどり着いていました
その振り5型のユニークナームや大会本番の会場で付け加えた
新たなパーツなどのおかげでなんとかギリギリ7大会を優勝することができたんです
そして全国大会に駒を進めることになります
中学2年生のわたしにとって全国大会なんて想像もつきませんでした
ましてやその先にある世界大会なんてなおさらです
でも出場できることになったんだからやれるだけのことはやろうと思って
なる財界から大幅な改良積んで全国大会にロボットを持って行きました
そしてそのロボットは全国大会に通用したんです
大会本番の立ち回りにおいて全国大会常連チームと下がったせいで優勝こそあのがした
んですけど
初めての全国大会を準優勝で終えることができました
そして世界大会に挑んでいくことになります
世界大会に向けてまたさらにロボットに改良を積んでいきました
特にロボットがミッションをクリアするスピードを詰めて全国大会のときに日本で最速
タイムだったものからさらに10秒ほどタイムを短縮しました
莫大な時間をかけて作り上げてきたロボットを開催国であるカタールまで持って行き
ました
練習会場でロボットを走らせると他国のロボットとの性能の差は一目瞭然でした
私たちなロボットはほとんどの国のロボットよりも早く
ミッションをクリアすることができたんです
それでいて抜群の安定感です
また振り子型のアームがユニークなものだったのでいろいろな国の人から
ロボットについて質問攻めにあったことも覚えています
間違いなく世界大会優勝候補の一角でした
注目と期待が集まりました
しかし
本番
その性能が発揮されることはありませんでした
ロボットはこれまでに見たことないようなエラーやセンサートラブルで誤作動を起こし
て練習通りに動くことはなく
結果は予選敗退で終わってしまいました
ん
何百何千時間と時間をかけて作り上げて来たロボットが世界の頂点のほんの少し手前
まで上り詰めたのにもかかわらずそれを逃してしまうと言う
悔しいという言葉では表しきれないほどの悔しさを体感して今でもそれを鮮明に
思い出せます
例えばここで私がロボット競技をやめていたらどうなっていたでしょうか
日本代表としてカタールまでロボットを持って行ったのにもかかわらず何の成果も残す
ことができず
一緒に頑張ってきたチームメンバーをはじめ
応援してくれた科学部のみんなや支えてくれた家族や顧問の先生などの色々な人の期待
を裏切ってしまった歯医者という肩書きを背負うことになっていたでしょう
私はそんな状況を脱するために次のようなことを考えました
歯医者にならない方法があるとすれば
それは挑戦者であることだということです
挑戦者という立ち位置こそがその時の私を歯医者から引き上げてくれる唯一の立ち位置
でした
私にとって挑戦者とは歯医者でも勝者でもない
無限の可能性に満ちた魔法のポジションでした
その考えを胸に中学3年生になった私は受験勉強と並行しながら
ロボット競技を続けることになります
今年こそは世界大会で優勝してやるぞと意気込んでロボットを開発したんですけど
その努力は空回り奈良大会で敗退することになってしまいました
これで中学生としての wro は幕を閉じることになります
それでもやはり歯医者にならない方法は挑戦者であることという考えの元高校生になっ
ても
wr を続けようと決意します
高校に入学した私は
ロボット研究会に所属して高校生としてロボット競技を始めることになりました
しかし高校で最初の w あろうは奈良大会は
突破することができたんですけど今度は全国大会で敗退することになりました
それでも now
歯医者にならない方法は挑戦者であることということを信じて
高校2年生もロボット競技を続けました
そしてついになら大会を優勝し全国大会を優勝し世界大会の出場権を獲得しました
中学2年生の時から3年かけてようやく世界大会の舞台に戻ってきました
これまでの経験をフルに生かしてロボットを開発しました
試奏何十回何百回と繰り返して
失敗を分析して適切な改良を施して日本では最速で安定してミッションをクリアー
できる
ロボットになっていました
中学2年生の時の世界大会の日駅を決して繰り返さないように
本番で練習通りにロボットが動くように入念に準備を重ねに重ねてタイで開催された
世界大会に挑みました
そして結果は
満点フルスコアで世界第6位入賞でした
無事にリベンジを果たすことができたんです
ここでその世界大会の競技本番の様子を少しご覧ください
me
ん
それゆえに
ええええええ
dj たしね
ね rejet れ
あああああし悪い i am
ni
あったわけじゃないです
hello world 1 has her
ani
uh
ni
悪いん
のが発表する
作った
ni
歯医者にならない方法は挑戦者であることという考えを信じて挑戦し続けてきたから
こそ
高校2年生の時に世界大会でリベンジすることができたんだと思います
中学2年生の時に世界大会で負けてその後3年間も負け続けてようやく
高校2年生で実現したリベンジです
中学2年生の敗北を機にロボット競技をやめていれば世界大会に出場したけど何の成果
も残すことができなかった人になっていた市本小1年生の敗北を機に辞めていれば世界
大会のリベンジを果たそうとしたけどできなかった人になっていたと思います挑戦し
続けてきたからこそ
ついてきた今の結果です
私たちの毎日は失敗に溢れています
その失敗は日々の何気ない小さな失敗かもしれないし
あなたの人生を左右するような大きな失敗かもしれません
そしてその失敗は私たちを朝鮮から遠ざけ落とせるでしょう
でもそれは違います
失敗してもあともう1回だけ行ってみるうまくいかなくても
あともう一歩だけ前に住んでみるそんなことの繰り返しが自分が望む未来を見る
簡単だけど難しい唯一の方法だと僕は思います
そんな私も高校3年生では世界大会で戦った
ライバルたちに後れを取らないためにまたダブルあろうに参加してこれまで作った
ロボット中で最高傑作と言えるほどがロボットを作ったんですけど
おまた今度は全国大会で敗退することになっています
しかし大学に入っていまロボコンサークルに所属してこれまでのロボット競技では達成
することができなかった
より高度な領域でプログラミングや制御理論を学び続けています
そしてまた今も挑戦者として新たな仲間と共にこれまで達成することができなかった
世界一を目指しています
あなたは何に挑戦しますか
あなたが見たい未来はいつも挑戦の先にあります
[拍手]
[音楽]